no gag oh hello everyone today I'm here
with Dave hi
I'm also floor gang this is not good
good wait what's that not a chair what
no no I mean it is wait I'm kind of
stuck between a rock and a hard place it
no that's not a check good good keep it
that way I just extended the floor you
remodel just to fit in yeah I get it
I'm sitting on the actual floor now
because I got shame for sitting on
pillows it's flooring game for life it's
very uncomfortable
all right so today we're gonna look at
reddit yeah yeah this is Dave's favorite
reddit he's been talking about this for
days yeah I I can't get enough that I'll
technically the truth what is something
that is technically the truth on top
over the head I am NOT okay I am
technically okay it's a but in the heart
I think everyone watching this is in the
heart is ball game that's good that's
good
all right well let's see what this red
is is all about I'd really like to hear
the reasoning behind women who won't
take their husband's last name because
my last name is best that's great
no that's the Sully pun I would actually
marry someone just to get that name
sorry my tre mafia Dave best Dave best
sounds pretty nice yeah I think I've got
one of the most common names in the
world
David Brown what's a little fun fact
about yourself I turned 11 on 11/11/11
edit 1111 I appreciate this
hey I appreciate this it's the same in
Sweden is it the date stuff is England
honestly I don't remember I do open 11
11 I know it makes sense in UK that's
one of the things you had that's working
out for you does I it makes sense these
huge companies all started from a garage
what's your Excuse I don't have a garage
that's yeah I like this this is petty
top-tier petty
if only I had a garage then I would be
successful too
this name was not in my garage that's a
shed dude seriously Disney star
ever said I don't know I didn't know
that that's kind of cool yeah this looks
like nice houses okay privilege I've
seen this one it's so good
exactly bro today we march to our planet
for our kids and for their future nice
you don't need too much bro you're
littering I get it but at the same like
its nicest leaders participating but at
the same he's gotta change some people's
minds but yet technically I appreciate
the Nick on camera strap with it oh it's
a camera I don't even notice oh I mean I
knew that I mean you're allowed to use
this jar okay telling a dangerously
overweight person not to lose weight
because they're beautiful it's like
telling an alcoholic not to stop
drinking because they're fun this is
true well I think that's just true where
does the technically start coming in I
yeah all right that's a good point like
this isn't annoying me in anyway it's
not like yeah suppose you're right it's
like yeah that's correct
small peepee question mark am I allowed
to designate peepee size or is that just
exclusive to you no no you're full of
gang absolutely okay small peepee next
that's all good
once you get a taste of that small
peepee power would you eat six donuts
honestly my takeaway from this chart is
that donuts actually true for me what do
you mean I didn't know no energy drink
oh my god you're right now I see it what
I think yeah okay still I think sugar
does worse than fat cuz a bunch of sugar
companies paid nevermind this is getting
too late
no I think you're right okay when does a
joke become a dad joke when it becomes
apparent technically the truth not
mildly infuriating but this is uh yeah
thank you link for nothing
waving verified link and assuming that
guys from Fire Emblem they're all from
Fire Emblem on they yeah Nintendo
Twitter never trusted lamps in video
games are using real electricity I like
this way my brain too small explain it
how does a PC or games console function
okay all right okay this is peak I think
this should have been the top of all
time this is brilliant
that's very technically the truth I want
to find a flaw in this no it's just true
this doesn't feel satisfying you know
why not it's like I don't know yeah
alright you're right it's like if
someone tells a joke that isn't fun yeah
I guess that was a joke
feels like a dad joke like uh yeah
alright yeah ok
we should definitely download all the
puns ok that wasn't a plan damn it so we
have Mexico Egypt and Indonesia from
three different places what does this
mean that my friend is exactly the
question you have to ask it means that
this is one of the best ways to pile up
rocks and not have them fall tough
that's really satisfying someone just
being sensible there oh my god yes so
many people believe like oh my god alien
the Egypt's like aliens yeah that's
gotta be in a coincidence they saw some
video or something right that's
something that's yeah coincidental but
can be risk his explaining the basics
[Laughter]
alright get on that Shane come on stop
making water videos Millennials aren't
buying diamonds why I can already answer
yeah it's like you in the picture there
no it does kind of look like me to be
sipping that java application to ask
them to attach their resume and then
enter what's on the same
may on the next page I am so glad that
I've managed to avoid doing that I am so
privileged Thanks I mean yes then that's
the better attitude that was another one
of the things that was a marketing
campaign to make people feel guilty for
not spending money right you have to
spend a third three months of your
salary on a dime and do that did you
[Laughter]
what exactly is the consequences of
being wrong about climate change even if
it all turned out to be a big mistake
oh no we've frickin made the world a
healthier and better place to live and
got ourselves off a renewable energy for
no reason how awful
yeah you telling me julius caesar who's
been dead for well over 70 years made
this salad 17 technically you are
drugged with that number but i just hate
it
wait why why Rita Rita again well over
oh my god has been dead for over three
months but I feel like that's what this
is a bread it should be about big peepee
I guess yeah I don't have the video
where they talked about how many women
they had slept with and they don't say
like up to this many they just say I've
slept with less than a thousand
somewhere in between less than a million
Elon Musk weed that's the solid ounce
for your chairs
I just chairs for your arms yeah this is
just a high throne yeah go away with
your shower thoughts alone we don't want
him hello bro are you good at math right
you are good at math right
hi yes I'm good if I cut the cake into
three pieces each piece will be 0.333 of
the main piece right correct okay if we
multiply 3 by 0.3 33 we get zero point
nine nine nine so what happened to zero
point zero zero one find it on the knife
oh thanks well
like the knife that's yeah that's how
rounding works as brilliant every single
a time in maths that there's like
top-tier mathematicians in the world now
using we find it on the knife I know
there's a bunch of annoying like math
things were like oh and one is actually
equals two if you do it like this just
add maths they don't yeah and maths the
idiots all right for the record right
chicken can't afford an umbrella so she
uses her wings she can't afford an
umbrella what she used her wings to keep
her chicks out of the rain yeah
technically she cannot afford that oh my
god I like how this is kind of hurting
you yeah I mean if she sold her chickens
she could afford a and that's legal
technically she could do that yes it
yeah so you're wrong David Bell in
reality plants are actually farming us
by giving us oxygen daily until we all
eventually decompose so they can consume
us I knew it I'm being in that or the
conspiracy I'm vegan wait if we can't I
hate plants that's a great concept see
this is a great reason for why we need
to keep destroying the earth because
otherwise we'll destroy us we can't let
the plants win guys come on calm planet
the planets plants actually feel pain I
remember I've heard about that yeah yes
of vegans I still like petting creatures
that seems like the Fedora version of
like its earlier VR you're vegan do you
know plants feel pain yes yes you're not
so sympathetic after all huh no I used
to be one of those proper auntie vegan
kids growing up when I went through ants
with my friends and even though veganism
was a thing when I was growing up I had
quite a few vegan friends when I went to
restaurants and they bought like a
vegetarian or vegan thing I would get
like the meat platter because I wasn't
at all
so out of character yeah I've changed
significantly hopefully it's like that
one clip of the guy who eats at steak in
front of their vegan right so that was
me I thought I was so cool I can't even
matter to begin being annoyed by that
unless you're right most of the time so
yeah it's like so are you vegan named
every Dave diet reveal that's the title
of this video now a single sperm has 37
point 5 megabytes of DNA information in
it
that means that a normal ejaculation
represent a data transfer of 1.5 hundred
oh one thousand five hundred and eighty
seven point five terrible that's a lotta
information to swallow oh yeah that's a
good joke I appreciate that you know
it's a good joke when I say out loud
it's a good joke yeah right it is
fascinating though how you can measure
the amount of data that can go on yeah
it's so far ahead of us biology it shows
how limited we are as a species as well
that's literally it
right if anything the plants should
right well I don't know how much that a
plant can I just meant like compared to
a computer Agnetha and I'm only 15 just
into Singh age 58 what's your Excuse I'm
only 27 right now fair fair cannot build
muscle at that age that does not work
that dude looks like a like a character
from a fighting game dude he looks
straight out of Joe you submit oh you're
right he just look like Soul Calibur
character something right that's so cool
well I could never lend this shirt to
anyone I'm flipping Robert Robert Downey
jr. I couldn't land it to you his wife I
could land it to your wife why am I so
slow
oh I'm king okay congratulations you
played yourself that's a pun but I'll
allow it
that's fine if it's an epic win like
that yeah against the epic man himself
that's got a war a swearword t-shirt is
always an epic win car companies always
advertise how quickly their cars go from
zero to a hundred but not a hundred to
zero even though it's a lot more
important that's a good point it's too
easy to cheat in that category by using
a wall I hate the subreddit now no Tom
chocolate tastes way better than theirs
so why don't talk lane oh yeah oh yeah
that's so unfunny stop it read it it's
technically the truth yeah I don't care
if it's technically the truth it's not
small peepee wait it says there so
technically it's not fair soap so
technically alive oh god um got him
learn English next time read it hey I
ran herself five she had a collab we've
all been waiting just a warning if
you're buying or watching Amazon I
learned the hard way that if it says you
can swim with it this only applies if
you can already swim without it oh my
god come on what is this you and then me
five seconds later get rich oh my god
dammit I think this shows that you've
done this too much like you think so
yeah there must have been a time in your
life where you to read that and $2.00 is
not a tip $5 is not a tip anything I'd
give you outside this mother mean bill
is the Ted technically the truth
technically the truth not really funny
no see they always seem to like that do
twins have the same size peepee
now we're asking the real questions as a
twin I can say my peepee is definitely
bigger than my sis I don't know have you
measured waiter when date I don't drink
waiter water me she said she doesn't
drink knock it off man
don't you understand she doesn't drink
that's literally actually me with my
sega's scheanette she doesn't drink a
lot even water I don't know how she does
it
that's what that sounds really unhealthy
yeah I don't know oh nice
cheers to you I don't know how she does
it she's not human we'll find out in
1977 we received a radio signal from
space that lasted 72 seconds and to this
day we still don't know where it came
from
dumbass is that one of those things
that's just everyone thinks is true but
it's not true at all I feel like it is
or that it's been already like explained
yeah exactly yeah it is funny though
because on there on the first satellite
that we sent out they may like this
pictures in them yeah yeah what's that
satellite call I guess it makes sense to
do it have math equations and stuff
right shows and tell yeah that's where
they had pictures of humans they've got
DNA down there oh wow oh wow that's so
cool
Hey look hideous find this oh and
there's someone twerking down there is
that what the hell is nice well what's
the point of adding centimeters why I
guess like comparable and then it's
kilograms like showing the weight I
guess I guess seconds makes sense right
yeah it's for measuring stuff what's
that seconds for what like how long they
live what I think so yeah how developed
it is I like this drawing someone had to
draw alright so we need you to draw like
this sick ass frog dude this is what
aliens will see they'll be like what the
small peepee
I think I Rama y know what these are the
things they chose to include all this
stuff the aliens think oh this is just
how they consume things all the time
pouring it from a gigantic blast for the
meetup ceremony then start pouring down
water I'm surprised no company like paid
to get their stuff in this oh my god
you're right there's so much with that
who's the real queen of the sea let's
argue Mona left her family to save her
village and the ocean area left her
family for Marin fare my son was just
born and another dad at the nursery
congratulated me and said his daughter
was born yesterday said maybe they'll
marry each other sure like my son is
gonna marry someone twice his age to be
honest it's not premarital sex if you
never get married
I thoroughly appreciate this one she
found a loophole yeah yeah
does that mean you wouldn't be sinning
isn't it weird how we pay money to see
other people
you mean prostitution concerts or the
movies glasses nice I like the fake Jim
and they set this up just for him
you mean right all right I saw my boy
cry across the bar tell some girl he
travels for work that man that's smooth
that got me more than it should have
it's still smooth technically true take
a tree I love that take out means dating
and murder take him out if you're a
praying mantis it can be all three at
once
oh yeah cuz they yeah all right dating
technically a praying mantis cannot
understand the concept of dating okay
your shoes are on the wrong feet
I don't have any other feet fair enough
I feel like this was one of those things
that some parent pretended that child
said all right yeah look at my child how
quirky yeah
what a fun view they have on life I wish
I was yes they enjoy jokes like that
happy you're painting the answer like
the word just cuz I don't like a joke
I'm not saying that all right I think
you're happier than I expected you to be
like you from knowing you like from a
distance my assumption was that you
would have some like making this kind of
thing so regularly I thought yeah surely
he's depressed then I met you I'm like
oh god he's not well it is making me
more depressed as we go so you're not
wrong one time I went to hand someone a
bowl of hot soup and my brain tried to
say careful it's hot and here's your
soup so instead I bloated Apple too
careful it's ooh yeah you should be
careful if it is hot okay let's see
what's on your mind it's freaking weird
that in order to go to sleep you have to
pretend like you're as seen this yeah I
don't pretend that I'm sleeping
technically a lie technically falls and
ER get the flip out of here small peepee
wait wait wait Santa's on the floor big
baby I mean I guess it's just like it's
feel like we're being weighted me
observation you did it sander yeah you
did it good from the floor that's where
all the deep thinking goes right
guarantee you yeah
Newton yeah we was on the floor wasn't
he when they're right he was under a
tree on the floor yeah that's what
people say when that out in like the
park or something I'm going for a walk
on the floor what's that what's the
other one with the water they yell at
Eureka and it was in a bathtub that's
floor yeah
he jumps out of the bathtub onto the
floor
behind a fire famously walked on the
floor oh this is like a pyramid yeah
except knows the truth nothing
worthwhile has been discovered sitting
down I think on it on a chair I think
that's the thing we know absolutely not
being a serial killer is much like being
a comedian in that you either hit it big
and yet your own Netflix special or you
spend eternity popping up on this is
great oh that's so true but I do feel
like they all show up anyway right it's
so weird how like no one has a problem
with like making serial killers super
famous wait I missed a point being a
snare kill as much like being a comedian
right it's a real jerk
that's clever yeah that's the first
really clever joke we've come across it
yeah yeah yeah okay so I'm not the only
one with that emotion then yes oh good
good that's bad that's why we're here
okay
that's why we figure that we finally
understand the subreddit weasel I got
the wrong emotion sorry about that but
yeah there's one correct emotion to have
here and I it was so fun check out
Dave's channel he uploads once every
year and which is my fault
and yeah well they should be the new
stuff coming maybe maybe we haven't
figured we'll see like this subscribe
and cheers to your gamers from the floor
to another floor in a world where
science knows
boundaries travel to land where no tuber
has been and explore never-before-seen
landscapes encounter beings that are
extinct lead by on actor's ancestors who
collect ancient items rediscover your
favorite scientifically accurate dinos
what will you create
you